وخطوره الزلزال المشاهدين لا تتوقفوا مع
نهايته بل تستمر عبر الهزات الارتداديه
التي تكون قوتها اضعف نسبيا من الهزه
الرئيسيه وقد تكون موجه الهزات الارتداديه
لم تنتهي بعد في تركيا حيث اشار التوقعات
الى امكانيه حدوث هزه ارتداديه قويه في
الايام القادمه صاحب التنبؤ ليس الا
العالم الهولندي فرانك
الذي توقع حدوث زلزال التركي السوري قبل
ثلاثه ايام من وقوعه هذا العالم الهولندي
اشار الى امكانيه حدوث هزه ارتداديه ربما
قد تصل شدتها الى السته درجات وقد تحدث
بوسط تركيا او حولها في الايام المقبله
ونشر العالم الهولندي هذا التوقع على
حسابه على تويتر لهيئه المسح الهندسي
للنظام الشمسي في هولندا الذي يشغل فيه
منصب الرئيس التنفيذي غير ان هذه التوقعات
يقول منتقلوها بانها ليست دقيقه